when the air pod pros first came out
about two months ago we expected them to
do well but nobody expected them to
instantly sellout and have such high
demand that they're sold out on Amazon
and a whole one month out buying
directly from Apple fortunately I
ordered them as soon as they went up for
sale so I've been using them for the
past two and a half months so in this
video I'll tell you guys when I think
about them long term and I'll discuss
what Apple got right with this version
of the air pods although Apple says that
the pros get slightly worse battery life
than the regular air pause I've actually
noticed the opposite it not only seems
like I'm getting better battery life
with the active noise cancellation
feature turned off but also with them
being enabled as well this really comes
in after the latest firmware update for
the air pods pros where I started
noticing a good boost in battery life so
be sure that your air Potts pros are on
the latest firmware compared to the
original air pause the pros also seem
like they have much better standby
battery life when you don't use them for
a couple of days compared to my old air
pods which seem to drain more quickly
but I'm guessing that's because of the
larger battery capacity in general
better battery life is something that it
didn't expect since the noise
cancellation works so well that you
would guess that they would drain much
quicker but it seems the Apple made it
super efficient compared to other
headphones with active noise
cancellation a lot of people are arguing
that the noise cancellation on the air
pipe pros isn't the best especially when
compared to the Sony WF 1000 XM 3s but
honestly for anybody who isn't an
audiophile the noise cancellation is
great and does a job more than good
enough yes it's not as good as very good
over the ear headphones with much larger
drivers but ever since I got the air pod
pros I really haven't been using my Sony
ex and three over the ear headphones and
I think I might end up just selling them
now if you have an experienced active
noise cancellation it basically creates
a peaceful environment blocking out
background noise no matter where you're
at allowing you to lower the volume of
your music and better enjoy music
listening as well as podcasts and other
audio now with the original air pods
which didn't seal in your ear and didn't
have noise cancellation you would have
to turn up the volume to block out noise
and not everybody wants to have music
blaring in their ears all the time
this feature alone makes the air pod
pros well worth it says he won't be
damaging your ears in the long term now
iOS 13.2 came out right around the same
time as the air pod pros and with it
came a new feature called announced
messages with Siri on air pods now while
you can also get this feature on a few
other Apple products I absolutely love
it because as soon as I get a message
Siri reads it out to me right into my
ear pods and I can even use series to
reply without ever picking up my phone
this is basically the hands-free future
the Apple has been trying to achieve for
years
and I'm surprised by how well it works
hey Siri on air pods pros works
incredibly well thanks to the extra
sensors that detect your speech I can
honestly say that it works every single
time so it's very reliable it works so
well that I haven't really been using
the new press controls on the air pod
pros even though there's so much better
than the old double tap controls on the
original air pods
every time you press down on the stem
you get an action and it plays a little
chime in your ear to confirm that it is
working but since hey Siri works oh well
I really only use it to switch between
noise cancellation modes and every so
often when my phone switches to another
bluetooth device a quick press is all it
takes to switch back to the air pots
with that said it is nice to know that
it's always there and it works great I
also love how well they work in the
Apple ecosystem ear pods Pro are
instantly connected to all of my Apple
devices so let's say I'm on my macbook
pro and i want to switch to listening on
my pros i just go up into the sound menu
and switch to them having that extra
level of convenience as a big deal and
it could just be software improves over
time but air pod pros seem to be a
little bit quicker and more reliable
when switching compared to air pods -
and as far as sound quality while they
may not be the best out there they sound
really good especially considering the
entire package you're getting with the
air pods pros now I want to transition
over to what Apple did right with the
air pods Pro considering the issues with
the original air pods one of the biggest
reasons why people didn't want to buy
air pods were because of the long stem
design they honestly did look a little
weird compared to with the earphones
that people are used to using but with
air pod pros they've greatly reduced the
length of the stem making it actually
look pretty nice and not taking up too
much attention
and the new contrast see dark vent on
the outside also adds to the nice look
people also complained about the lack of
sweat and water resistance and now the
air pods produ have that and I think
that's a big reason why Apple is
actually discounting the powerbeats pros
and they don't seem to be selling quite
well where these are sold out another
reason people didn't buy air pods was
because of the lack of base and that's
mainly due to the fact that the original
ear pods didn't seal in your ears a
feature that is very important for base
reproduction
kudos to Apple for not only including
different tip sizes but also having a
special piece of software which will
test and see if you have a good fit to
make sure you're getting the best sound
and along with that they are also
selling replacement tips for a fairly
reasonable price the pros not only seal
in your ears but the new venting feature
equalizes the pressure inside of your
ear canal to match the environment so it
never really feels like your ears are
plugged up like they do with most other
sealing earbuds it's basically the best
of both worlds allowing the pros to feel
almost as comfortable as the original
ear pods for most people and way more
comfortable for a lot of others while
providing the seal that allows for
better bass and to block out different
noise not only that but the airport pros
also seem like they are the first sealed
earphones to get rid of that plastic
little tube that goes into your ear
canal which adds to the discomfort
during longer listening sessions this is
a huge deal and it works together with
the new venting feature and the new
transparency mode which make the air pod
pros the most comfortable sealing
headphones I have ever used people
complained about connectivity issues
with the original ear pods but with
Apple's new h1 chip and the constant
software updates issues have gone down
dramatically and they are much more
reliable now I know that the pros don't
have the most bass output out there
which some people really want a lot of
but I've also noticed that the sound
quality and the quality of the bass
itself is very clean and accurate
compared to say the galaxy buds and to
me that is much more important than
having heavy rumbling bass and every
song that I listen to the new adaptive
EQ is also a huge deal there's actually
a microphone on the inside of the ear
pods pros that faces the speaker
Alissa's to any distortion in Tunes the
frequencies specifically to your ear
canal just to
sure that there is no distortion and
that everything sounds great this is
similar to what I've done with my home
theater surround sound system tuning the
speakers to the room to get the very
best sound this also ensures that your
air pod pros won't start sounding worse
over time just like car stereo speakers
do when you keep blasting them all the
time because of that tuning they're
gonna have a consistent nice sound so
with Apple fixing all those prior issues
and making the air pods Pro look better
than before it makes sense why they are
selling so well they're definitely
expensive but if you're willing to dish
out that much cash
you won't be disappointed just the fact
alone that the air pod pros have been
sold out for so long speaks for itself
it's a quality accessory that's better
than basically every other earphone out
there if you consider the complete
package and if you're in the Apple
ecosystem the original air pods were
hugely successful as well and it's
awesome that Apple is able to create a
sequel to the air pots that was that
much better and for that reason the air
pod pros are Apple's masterpiece pushing
the brand name ahead for years to come
and it's hard to imagine what else they
can add or improve to make these better
in the future if you have any thoughts
let me know in the comment section below
so if you want to get your hands on a
pair of ear pods Pro check the Amazon
link below to see if they're finally
back in stock and if you're not already
subscribed click that little circle
above to do so now and check out one of
these two ear pods Pro videos right over
there to learn more thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]